All right, I really want your take on these.
All right, first up Tinks,
Metro reports singles are trying out
something called the zero date.
And it's a predate to decide
if they even want go on a first date.
And you can do it on the phone or on Zoom,
so after you meet online you just
make an appointment to do this.
It's quick, you can feel each other out,
just a little tiny example
to see if you wanna order the whole entree,
and then maybe have dessert later.
If you know what I mean?
But do you recommend this, especially for online daters
to do some sort of facey time thing?
I like it,
I like it as a little bit of a pre-check.
Because how many times have you sat down at a drink's date,
or even worse, a dinner date.
Yeah.
And immediately first five seconds you know
there's just no dice.
We are just not gonna get along,
there's nothing for us to talk about, we don't vibe.
And oftentimes, you connect with someone so instantly,
so why not give them a quick FaceTime?
Exactly.
(crowd applauding)
And then it's so great,
you know you're not gonna be catfished.
Exactly.
You don't have the insecurity of
are they gonna think I'm cute in person?
Hello, they just saw you.
Make sure you hold the angle here,
hold it here, hold it in every--
I love that picture the person had the wine,
and they're in their recliner.
Put a little red wine
on there, set the scene.
Let me ask you some advice,
because this is something I have just recently learned.
I had gone on some dates over the last few years,
and they were always a meal.
And I did have of couple circumstances,
okay, see, your reaction says at all.
You can't, you can't do a first dinner date.
Okay, thank you.
Then you're locked in.
Well, I didn't know this.
Oh my God, haven't you ever gone a dinner date,
you sit down and like you haven't even gotten bread yet,
and you're already like,
"So where did you grow up you said?"
You're just pulling it straws to keep it going.
Totally, I did that with almost all of them.
Yeah, yeah exactly.
And then you're trying to eat your pasta, and
keep the conversation going.
And then they want to have
appetizers or mains, you're like, "Nothing."
You're like, "Check, check."
Check.
I can't not be, I'm not rude.
Yeah, yeah.
And then I also wanna be like, "Oh, give it a minute.
But not maybe a minute, like 72."
Exactly, exactly.
After living and learning I agree too.
Yeah, I'm with you.
Well, this I like,
we've got some good news in the fight against ghosting.
I love this.
(Ross laughing)
We have some good news in the fight against ghosting,
if that didn't have me at hello nothing will.
Fast Company reports there is a new dating app called Snack,
and it's taking steps to actually ghost the ghosts.
Users can report someone when they have just
disappeared on them.
And the app will flag those profiles,
and slowly make them less visible to everyone else.
Put them down lower in the line if you know what I mean.
Ghosts you've been poofed.
(laughs) Yeah.
So I like it.
Yeah.
What comes around goes around.
Tinks thoughts.
I love that, I love that so much,
because you know what?
Ghosting is very cowardly, and I don't think that
we should be encouraging that type of dating.
(audience applauding)
How hard is it to send a text or a message,
"Sorry, I didn't vibe with you on the first date.
Best of luck out there."
It takes two seconds, and it seems so scary,
but it's just the, the adult, mature, honest,
kind thing to do.
(upbeat music)